[MUSIC PLAYING]
CECILIA: I'm super excited
to have Robin Lowey today
that has joined us to talk
about her "Game Changers" book.
And both Google and Gagglers
are happy to welcome you,
and I know she's going
to give her life story.
So without further ado, Robin.
Thank you.
ROBIN LOWEY: Thank you, Cecilia.
Gosh, what a pleasure.
[APPLAUSE]
What a pleasure to be
here with you guys.
Let's see, I wanted
to just start out
with a quick introduction.
My name's Robin
Lowey, as she said.
And I started this blog called
"Epochalips: Smart Lesbian
Commentary" about
eight years ago,
just inviting lesbians to
like tell their stories,
and I publish events and just
interesting things, authors,
things like that.
So it kind of led
me to the book.
But before we get
started, I wanted
to just ask your advice about--
about my Halloween costume.
I had two choices.
One is the clowns.
And these are clown candidates.
It says, you know, vote Flappy
and Crappy for Congress.
That was pretty funny.
So we tried that one on, and
we tried on the cat costume
so which do you
think we should do?
AUDIENCE: Cats.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] clowns.
ROBIN LOWEY: Oh,
you like clowns.
That's so good.
So they scare people.
Anyway, I'd like to be a
little scarier than-- you know,
I don't know.
Anyway--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] tonight.
ROBIN LOWEY: OK.
Yeah, maybe we'll do that.
So this is the agenda today.
We're just going to talk
a little bit about me
and a few other things.
You can take a look at that.
And we have some good giveaways.
OK, growing up, I didn't
have any role models really.
It was a pretty scary
time in the '60s and '70s.
And when I first moved here
to California from Chicago,
I was about seven.
And I rode my Stingray around.
It looked just like that,
actually, and without a shirt
on until that just
wasn't OK anymore.
And what we did was--
what I did was like beat
up boys after school.
We'd sneak out at night.
We were just trouble,
my friends and I.
And, you know, it became
evident early on that--
that I really liked
girls, and I was just--
I would stand in front of the
mirror, and flex my muscles,
and I had two ideas in my head
that I was sure about, one
that I was never
going to marry a man,
and, two, that I was never
going to have a baby.
So those things ended up--
one of them ended up changing.
But I was so--
I couldn't have been more
sure of anything in my life.
Now, I also was a
big sandlot softball
player, baseball player.
And I wanted to play
Little League so bad.
And I was really good.
And at that time-- and
this was pre Title IX.
If you can imagine, they
didn't have to let girls play.
So I wasn't allowed to play.
So I joined a bobby
socks softball
team, which was called
the Great American Girls.
And we had a coach who was
kind of a butchy mom type.
And we all had big brothers,
and we played so hard.
We were sliding into home
and saying no batter.
And we handily won
the championship,
and then at the end when they
were passing out the trophies,
it ended up that
they said, I'm sorry,
but the great American
girls are disqualified.
We're going to give the
trophy to the Buttercups
because the Great
American Girls did not
play in a lady-like manner.
So if you can
imagine a time when
it was not OK to be
competitive or a tomboy--
so that was the message I was
getting pretty loud and clear.
OK, so then when I
became a teenager,
I applied to be a park ranger.
And I became the
first park ranger.
This is a shot of me with
a current park ranger
that I ran into,
and I didn't have
to wear the man pants
and the man boots.
At the time, I could wear like
cute tennis shoes and really
tight pants, like the
kind that you lay down
and zip up and a big old shirt
with badges and a big key ring.
And I just thought
that was so cool.
And I would stand around
daydreaming about the girl I
was crushed out on.
Then I got to high school.
And I really tried
hard to be straight.
You know, I had a very
feminine look, and I just--
I got a lot of
attention from men,
and so I just didn't
know what to do.
So I tried really hard,
and it didn't work.
When I got to college,
I went to a summer
in Europe, where I met
another woman who was also
had never been with a girl, and
we both were stumbling around.
It was a very awkward time.
But we got through it.
And then after that, I finally
moved to San Francisco, where
I finally found my people.
And we lived on
Castro Street in 1982.
I met this woman, and
we started a family
after about seven years.
We each had a boy.
My brother was the
donor for the older boy.
And then she couldn't get
pregnant again the second time
we wanted to, and
so I had to step up,
and it was terribly difficult
as an athlete to be pregnant.
And that picture on the
bottom is my son and I.
We look exactly the same.
I gotta say, it's one of
the most empowering things
that I've ever been
through, like an Amazon,
like to give birth, like, here
I was a little kid thinking
I can never do this, and it
ended up being really awesome
except for ruining my body,
and he cried for five-years
straight pretty much.
But when he got a little
older-- and it was cool
because I couldn't have
really had a baby with a man.
I wasn't really that
great with infants.
And my ex partner loved
to just stay home.
I worked really hard.
I was so happy to
go back to work,
and she took care
of the infants.
And so they're really good kids.
So then at this
time, we head to--
OK, we were the first
wave of parents.
Other people were having
children that were older
than us, but there was
no real group of parents.
So we were in San
Francisco at this time
when we had like a gay PTA, and
we had a very inclusive campus,
and it was just-- it
was nice, you know?
But we still had
to do this thing
where we adopted each other's
kids because we couldn't
be legally the parent
of our own child-- or I
couldn't be the legal parent
of the child she gave birth to
and vice versa.
So we had to literally give
up our children to each other,
and the judge would just--
I remember we had to
go to court twice,
and he would just like
point at us and say,
are you sure you want
to give up your child?
And I'm like, oh my god,
it was really intense.
And then we got married.
We went down to City Hall.
Gavin Newsom made
it OK to go down.
And we ran down there,
and it was exciting.
And my youngest
was eight, and he
was like, oh, yay, this means
you'll be married forever.
You'll always be together.
And, unfortunately,
that wasn't the case.
But what happened that
was cool about that
was that he-- you know,
he just felt so validated
by us being able to be married.
So I feel like that's
such an important--
it's just an
important thing when
you think about the whole
right for same-sex marriage,
that the kids are the ones that
are being hurt by it so much.
So we got our marriage
certificate mailed back
to us after about--
I think it was less than a month
later, it arrived in the mail
as annulled, because
the law didn't stick.
So then at that point,
we moved to Marin County.
That's where I grew
up, as you saw.
And I wanted my kids to
have a more rural existence.
So I brought them to Marin,
and my oldest came home saying,
oh, god, mommy, why is everybody
saying you're so gay, you fag.
And he just didn't understand.
It was shocking for him.
And I was like, well, we're
not living in San Francisco
it's not a bubble anymore.
So he became the kind of kid
who told his friends, look,
I'm not going to be your friend
if you say stuff like that,
and you know, I don't know.
I got-- I got motivated
to go into the schools
and become a speaker for
the LGBT Speakers Bureau,
to be a coach for the
Little League team,
to coach for soccer, and just
be visible and like help them.
I mean, like,
things would happen,
like, I'd have kids over for
the soccer party and I'd say,
Timmy, what are you
doing out there?
And he'd say, oh, we're playing
smear the queer, you know,
in the backyard.
I'm like, what?
And, you know, so--
and it just went on and on.
Some of the dads would say, wow,
you really remind me of Ellen,
and I'm like, why?
I don't look like her.
And we just had--
there was a lot of
homophobia in Marin,
and I think about all the
people in the outlying areas
right now.
I mean, we live
in such a bubble.
So I got the idea to write this
book, which is about lesbian
heroes of my generation.
And the women that they
looked up to weren't--
it wasn't like they were bad.
It was just that the role
models weren't very positive.
So they passed a law called,
the Fair Education Act
kind of recently, and it
really got me excited,
like, this was something
that I could contribute to.
I could-- I'm a graphic
designer, and an editor,
and a curator.
And I have a huge circle
of people that I know.
And I just thought I can make a
really fun book that teenagers
are going to love.
And so what this law does is it
requires LGBT education as far
as history and social
studies in the public school
curriculum in California.
And right now, there
it's not really
like the curriculum exists.
It's not like really
there's resources for them.
I attended a
symposium last week,
or two weeks ago,
where we got in a room
and did a whole big think
tank about how we're
going to get this to happen.
And it's clearly
a couple years out
before there'll really
be a lot of things
available to students.
And especially public schools
don't have a lot of resources
to spend on stuff like this.
So I got it in my head that
I wanted to make this book
and donate it to the
public high schools
in Marin, San Francisco,
Oakland, and Berkeley.
So what I did was I
decided to go crowdfunding.
And I got to say, if
you're a little insecure,
and you have a full time job,
this is a brutal way to go.
I was-- it was so excruciating.
I went at it--
two different runs at it,
each for about $10,000.
And, no, the money's
not all from my family.
It really did get spread
out amongst about 200 people
at an average of
about $100 each.
It required, you know, live
Facebook videos, you know, yay,
you know, so scary.
Anyway, so I got all
that money, and then
I was able to print
the books, and I
was able to deliver them to
the 48 public high schools,
and it serves about
49,000 students now.
And these schools
have invited me in
to talk in their classroom.
I've been able to just
share with these kids
and hear their stories.
And I had one girl
come up to me just
in tears saying,
oh, my god, I can't
believe you're really here.
And she had--
I had these books
kind of sprinkled
around some bookstores
too like in the Castro.
And she said, I got
your book in the Castro.
And I'm-- I'm just--
I can't believe it, you know?
She was hugging me and crying.
It was like so gratifying.
So I wanted to show you
my crowdfunding video.
See if I can get this to play.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- My name is Robin
Lowey, and I've
been curator and editor of
"Epochalips: Smart Lesbian
Commentary" for
the past six years.
As a pioneering lesbian
mom with two grown sons,
I turned to my
youngest, Sam, age 20,
to talk about what this book
means to him personally.
- I was raised in Marin
County by two lesbian moms.
As I grew up and went to
elementary and middle school,
I noticed that we were never
taught about gay people
or their history.
So because of that
lack of education,
gay slurs were
rampant around campus,
and it was always kind
of a struggle for me.
I think it can help not only
heterosexual students that
are unclear about what
being gay really means,
as well as kids that might
be coming out of the closet
and just want to find their
own place in the world
and be accepted in life.
- If you could spread
the word to your network,
it would be a great help.
So thank you so
much for your time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
ROBIN LOWEY: Anyway, I asked him
to say that in his own words,
and he kind of gave
me a hard time.
He's, like, I'm not going to--
I don't-- mommy, I don't
know what-- you know?
And I was like, oh,
no, and then I just--
and then one day, he
goes, OK, I'm ready.
And I just went outside and
filmed him with my iPhone.
I got pretty lucky there.
It's a good boy, and he's not--
he's-- yeah.
Anyway, so then I
also got books ordered
from schools and libraries
all over the United States.
People were hitting me up in
like North Carolina, and Texas,
and it was just-- it's
been super exciting.
I'm down to my last few books,
which I brought for you guys
to raffle off.
So you're pretty lucky.
Then I won an award
for the best LGBTQ book
by this Next Generation Indie
Book Awards, which was quite--
it's quite an
honor, and I really
didn't understand that
it was such an honor.
I was kind of like,
oh, I got this award,
and then someone
told me, I've been
trying to win that for years.
I can't believe you--
had anyway.
So here's a brief
history of queer culture.
I just want to back
up a little bit
and talk about that the
women in the book, this
is the kind of world
that I was a little girl,
and they were little girls in.
This is what we had.
OK, so there's Sappho, who
obviously was the first written
word of a sonnet
to another woman
that is arguably like the
beginning of lesbianism.
And then Radclyffe Hall
came along in like 1929,
and she wrote a book called
"The Well of Loneliness."
It was in the court
system in the UK
for a long time for obscenity.
And it finally
made it to the US.
There was no explicit
sexual content
in this book whatsoever.
It was just that there was
a mannish heroine, who was--
I guess she liked girls.
And then Gertrude Stein was--
in the 1930s, she was the
first visible lesbian here
in America.
She was from Oakland,
and she wrote
those famous quotes, a
rose is a rose is a rose,
and there is no there there,
in regards to Oakland.
And she ran a salon like in
Paris with people like F. Scott
Fitzgerald, and
Ernest Hemingway,
and Matisse, Picasso, all
these big thinkers at the time
would sit around and--
and then she got
famous for writing
the book about her
partner, Alice B. Toklas
called "The Autobiography
of Alice B. Toklas,"
which is kind of random.
She did it in the
voice of her partner.
And just as an added
fun fact, my parents
named our cat Alice
and then later came
to light that his name was--
her name was Alice B. Toklas.
This is when I
was a little girl.
So that happened.
OK, so then this genre
called pulp fiction emerged,
and it had to do with
just cheap paper.
That's why they called
it pulp fiction,
and it was the first
time that America
could buy just paperbacks
cheaply at a newsstand,
and, you know, you
might finish reading it
and leave it on
your seat on the bus
and someone else
would pick it up.
And so it was just
a way to get masses
to be reading literature.
And then within that genre, it
became lesbian pulp fiction,
and, oh, my notes.
Could you grab
those for me, Jane?
Anyway, so if you wrote
this book, a lot of times
that women had pseudonyms
that were men's names.
And you-- the publishers
required that you had to say--
you literally had to have
a heroine either die--
these are not them.
It's in my bag.
Anyway, back to-- back to
the lesbian pulp fiction.
So you had to have the heroine
either die, go back to men,
or go crazy, just like
the films at the time.
It was-- this is what
we had to look up to.
This is what we saw.
Yay!
Thank you, Jane.
OK, so I want to
just read you a quote
of a woman who is a kind
of an interesting writer.
She's probably 80 now.
So she said, "A lesbian
pulp fiction paperback first
appeared before my
disbelieving eyes
in Detroit, Michigan in 1957.
I didn't need to look
at the title for clues.
The cover leapt out at me
from the drugstore rack.
A young woman with sensuous--
sensuous intent on her face
seated on a bed, leaning
over a prone woman, her hands
on the other woman shoulders.
Overwhelming need led me
to walk a gauntlet of fear
up to the cash register, fear so
intense that I remember nothing
more, only that I stumbled
out of the store in possession
of what I knew I must have, a
book as necessary to me as air.
The book was 'Odd Girl
Out' by Ann Bannon.
I found it when I
was 18 years old.
It opened the door to my
soul and told me who I was,
and it led me to other
books that told some of us
who we were and how
some of us lived."
So just to imagine a time where
this-- something like this
would be so forbidden
and so awesome
to like not have any vision
of yourself out in the world.
And then you got
this kind of one
that wasn't so great because he
didn't have to die or go crazy.
So in this one, things started
to change a little in the '50s.
Women's barracks actually
was about a real couple
with a real relationship
a little bit.
And so it came under the
scrutiny of the house
un-American
Activities Committee,
where they had it
up for obscenity,
and they said, "Lesbianism
was a sociological
disease and a cause for
grave national concern.
It could not be cured.
But it must be
understood as a tragedy."
So it was accused of
promoting moral degeneracy.
This is because they crossed
that line where they weren't
having an unhappy ending.
And I mean, I'm actually
not sure about the ending,
but the fact that there
was a real relationship
was just too much, kind
of the McCarthy era
too or a little
later, but anyway--
but it helped really
increase the sales,
and they sold like four
million copies of that.
So this other book, "The
Price of Salt," this was--
did you see the
movie "Carol" that
came out a couple of years ago.
This was the movie with
Cate Blanchett, I guess.
And this was the movie
that they wrote it about.
And that one sort of
had a happy ending where
the woman got to stay together.
She lost her child,
but it wasn't all rosy.
Anyway, so during that same
time was an underground gay bar
culture.
And I guess it's saying that gay
men and lesbians were now seen
as a group to cure,
convert, and suppress.
So the American public started
to get wind of this thing,
and they got-- they
were getting really mad.
You can't be out in public.
And so they were
rounding up people.
This is around the
time of Stonewall.
So these women here--
there you know, it was a butch
and femme culture, and, like,
you--
you could get caught
for not wearing
three things of the same--
three articles of clothing
of the assigned gender
that you were, you
be thrown in jail.
So I'm not sure if I would be
thrown in jail, hopefully not.
But they had little signals,
like, they'd flash the lights.
And everyone would switch
to the opposite sex partners
so that they wouldn't be like
thrown in the paddy wagon,
but they were risking
everything, their jobs,
their lives, their families,
just to be able to congregate.
Now, at that same
time was this thing
called a couple of
different secret societies
daughters of elitists.
This is Phyllis
Lyon and Del Martin.
And their thing
was that they were
kind of the intellectual
set, and they didn't really
want to be associated with
like the working class,
butch-femme scene.
They wanted to be able to
have a literary magazine they
could send around.
And so they sent it in
like a brown paper bag.
And so people all
over the country
were getting some
culture now finally.
So now I'm going to talk
a little bit about my game
changers in the book.
So the way I set
this up was I chose
women who are not famous
in the world at large.
They're famous amongst the
gay and lesbian community.
So we have authors,
businesswomen, promoters,
actors, publishers,
entertainers, lawyers,
everybody that I
could gather together
that was connected to me on
some first or second degree that
was willing to give me
all these pieces I needed
to pull this book together.
So you don't see people like
Ellen and Rosie O'Donnell
and stuff in here because
they're already famous,
but it's more like our
heroes that actually created
real changes to the culture
for the young people
today to know about.
So this woman, Monica
Palacios, she was named--
they had a Monaco Palacios
day for her 30-year career,
as a kind of lesbian
performer and writer.
This is Judy Dlugacz.
She is the Olivia person.
So they started Olivia in
'73 as a music company,
and then now it's like
a multi-million dollar
corporation.
And she's doing really well.
And, you know, I've been
on a lot of these trips,
and I always find
it fascinating.
Women from across the country
that don't live in our bubble
save up all year long to be
able to afford this one week
to be able to hold
their partner's hand
and be out for a week.
It's incredible.
It's-- I always forget
just how lucky we are here.
And this woman, Crystal
Jang, is really interesting.
Each person had a page also
that had like a pull-out card,
which I'll show you.
But Crystal, she
was born and raised
in Chinatown, and as a young
woman in the '70s, during that
time, the Health Department
was sending people out
to different communities
to talk about, wow,
there's gay and lesbian
people in the community,
and you need to address this.
And so when they
got to Chinatown,
I guess the mayor of
Chinatown guy says, look,
we don't have any gay
people in Chinatown.
And so Crystal
was just a young--
I think she was an educator.
She could lose her job.
She stood up, and she said,
my name is Crystal Jang.
My parents are Esther and
Homer Jang, and I'm a lesbian.
And it just like
brought the house down,
and people were crying
and coming up to her.
And so she was the
first one to like
take a stand in the
Chinese community,
and it's just so important
she brought together
the whole Asian
community in one,
you know, as a force in the
gay and lesbian community
within that.
And Jewelle Gomez, this
is the fun fact cards
that are in the book.
They're like little
baseball cards.
She's a playwright.
She does lesbian vampire
novels, and she does, you know,
James Baldwin-inspired plays.
She's fantastic.
This is The Dinah.
This is Mariah Hanson.
And what people don't
know so much about her--
I don't know if you
know about The Dinah.
It's the largest lesbian
event in the world, I guess.
And zillions of lesbians
descend on Las Vegas,
I mean, Palm
Springs once a year.
And she has discovered acts
like Lady Gaga, Katy Perry.
She's the first one
to have them out.
And so that is really a
big hotspot for culture.
Kate Kendell, who as
leader of NCLR, she--
they are the ones that brought
gay marriage to be legal.
They're the ones that
fought the fight.
This is an interesting one.
This Diane
Anderson-Minshall, she's
a woman I worked with years ago.
And she had a partner that--
Suzy, just kind of a
average kind of quiet gal.
And then over the years,
Suzy transitioned to Jake.
And Jake is this swaggering,
handsome dude now.
And they are still
married all this time.
And then, you know,
this interests me
because it begs the question,
is she still a lesbian?
Well, she think she is.
I think she is.
So she belongs in there.
And this is Marga
Gomez, who I got to--
I heard that this
spit take thing became
like the most famous
meme on the internet,
and my son, the one in
the video, called me up.
Mommy, I keep seeing
Marga on video--
I mean, as a meme online.
So she's managing
to stay relevant.
She also has a show right
now in Berkeley called--
I forget the name.
But it's-- it's really--
AUDIENCE: "Latin Standards."
ROBIN LOWEY: "Latin
Standards," yeah, you
should definitely go see
that if you get a chance.
It's playing there
right now at The Marsh.
It's fantastic.
She plays her dad,
and her mom, and--
and this is Jenni Olson,
who is the person who
started PlanetOut.
I don't know if you
know about that.
That was one of the
very first websites
that meant so much to all of
us that our little older--
it was the first
place where you could
have a hub of all things gay.
And my mom takes a look at
this and says, is that a man?
And I say, no, that's
Jenni, and she's cute.
OK, so what's next
for game changers?
Well, I'm hoping to get it
into 267 more schools, which
would serve an additional 20--
over 200,000 students.
And that means every
county in the Bay
Area, every public high
school, would get a book,
and we put it--
you know, I put it in
the wellness centers
and the libraries.
I've heard from the wellness
center people in my hometown
how much it means to
those kids to just walk
in and like see
that on the table
because that's who's
typically going
into the wellness
center, someone
who's being bullied or
feeling a little awkward.
And if they can just pick
this up and have it not
be a big deal, it's huge.
And this is why
it's so important
because it's not just the gay
kids that are going to benefit.
It's the straight kids.
It's like, gosh, I don't
know, when I was little,
we didn't have
like a poster of--
Black History Month.
We didn't have Martin Luther
King in every classroom.
But now they have that.
So like I was picturing
soon, in a few years,
they'll probably have a
picture of Harvey Milk
in every classroom, a
poster, and that's all great.
But, like, I want to make
sure the lesbians are
included that did great things.
Because women are always left
out of stuff, and the history--
history is always about the
context with which you tell it.
So, now, oh, we lost it.
Ta da!
So the reasons
that it's so great,
obviously, is it
reduces bullying,
increases visibility, and
fosters pride and dignity,
like that girl who just was so
touched that I brought it in.
It just-- it's so important
for people to see themselves.
Otherwise, you just
feel invisible.
So I'm just asking you guys
to help spread the word today,
and I have a sign-up
sheet over there
if you want to keep in touch.
No.
Hello?
AUDIENCE: Did you
experience any challenges
when you tried to
distribute the books?
AUDIENCE: Sorry, can we
repeat that [INAUDIBLE]??
ROBIN LOWEY: She asked if we--
OK, she asked if I faced
any challenges when
trying to distribute the books.
And, yes, I got a couple of
books mailed back, and then--
but mostly no.
Everyone was thrilled
to get it, and I either
mailed it or personally sent--
walked into these schools
and gave it to them,
and I got all the right names
from some educator friends
so it was going to
the right people.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
This isn't about your
book, but your experience
of the challenge of parenting
in those situations.
And do you have any advice on
handling those situations where
you have other parents that
are not as open minded?
ROBIN LOWEY: Well, that's
a really good question.
AUDIENCE: And how you've
navigated that over time.
ROBIN LOWEY: Well, I can only
think of an anecdote that's
pretty funny.
When my partner and I
first moved to Marin,
some parents said to me, oh, we
always wanted a lesbian couple
in our circle of friends.
We were like, wow, that's--
that's exciting.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, I don't know.
I mean, I guess I just--
you know, my son is
actually-- my older son
is a real big advocate for that.
He'll just say, oh,
so you're against it?
I mean, like, you
think if I got hurt,
my mom shouldn't be able to
pick me up from the hospital?
Like just point out real facts
about the discrimination,
and I don't know.
It's a hard one.
It's very personal.
I guess I tried to steer
clear of it as much as I could
and give my kid the tools
to just be proud of himself
by surrounding him by a positive
environment and being proud.
Like, I'm really proud that
both my kids are feminists,
like they just really get
it about the discrimination,
and they consider
themselves queer.
They're both
straight, but they--
they know they were
raised by two women,
and that has changed them.
It has made them better men.
I was thinking, oh, god, you're
bringing two little white boys
into the world.
And, you know, at least
they've got this thing
that makes them
understand that, you know,
it's not the same level
playing field for all of us.
It's really important
to know that.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: Do you have
another question?
ROBIN LOWEY: Keep it going.
AUDIENCE: I'm dominating this.
OK, do you-- do you have
any recommendations for us
if we want to approach schools
as well to help distribute
your book?
ROBIN LOWEY: Well, you
could contact me afterwards.
I would love-- I
would love some help
with that, especially
when it comes
to delivering it down here.
I've applied for a
couple of grants,
and I'm also looking for
people to step up and help.
So any way you can help,
if it could be distributing
and something like that would
be fantastic, or giving me
the right people, and yeah, so
you could sign up over here,
and I'll be sure to be in touch.
AUDIENCE: I did have
somebody ping me
with a question which
is, first of all,
thank you for being here.
It's such an
important publication
and for documenting our history.
What are your thoughts
on how millennials
tend to identify more as queer,
that the word lesbian could
be fading from our lexicon?
ROBIN LOWEY: Oh, that's
a great question.
I will say that when I came out,
and the women around my age,
we didn't have a choice.
It wasn't a choice of
some version of queer.
It was-- it was you're
a lesbian or you're not.
Do you like women or not?
And if we were going to choose
that the harder way, you know,
then we were going to claim it.
And so now that it's become
kind of an un-PC word
to use in general for the youth,
I just have to question it.
I got a lot of actually flak.
I got people
e-mailing me saying,
do you have to use
that ugly word?
Can't you just say queer?
And I was like, no, because
it's about the lesbians.
I mean, that's the whole point.
But it's an interesting
part of history.
And it will fade, and it
is fading, and that's OK.
It's just it's important
to at least understand
why it was there what happened,
and why we have the freedoms
that we have today to choose
some version of gay, queer,
whatever, fluid?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ROBIN LOWEY: Yes?
AUDIENCE: My experience
growing up in Toronto
when I started to try
to tell people, I found
it hard to say I was a lesbian.
And I would say, you know,
so I would say, I'm gay,
like, there's something
about the stigma of saying
you're a lesbian--
ROBIN LOWEY: Well, you're right.
AUDIENCE: And it started
from the beginning.
ROBIN LOWEY: Good point.
AUDIENCE: So almost
in a way, we're
still not comfortable
saying we're lesbians.
ROBIN LOWEY: Right.
It's a misogynistic thought,
if you really think through.
Why is it so
uncomfortable to talk
about the woman part
of the gay thing
and identify strictly as that?
And when the word gay is such
a happy word, and lesbians,
like, oh.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
I really resonate
with that, and, yeah,
it's so interesting
how there's--
there's that little
hurdle about lesbian.
So you started
asking what we were
going to come to Halloween as.
And I figured it out.
I'm going to come as a
lesbian, you should know.
ROBIN LOWEY: That's great.
AUDIENCE: And I wondered if
you had any thoughts about what
my costume should look like?
ROBIN LOWEY: Well, I dressed as
a lesbian once for Halloween.
And I wore a very
misshapen pillow here,
and then a big old fanny
pack, and a mullet.
This was years ago.
I can't believe I did that.
AUDIENCE: But that's different
than a lesbian you should know.
ROBIN LOWEY: Right, of course.
Hmm.
AUDIENCE: Maybe do
Gertrude Stein, where
you could cut your--
ROBIN LOWEY: Jane was in a play
where she played Gertrude--
she--
there was a play called, "All
These Different Gertrudes,"
and Jane literally cut
her hair for the part
that night, the worst
haircut I've ever seen.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ROBIN LOWEY: OK, that's
a deal breaker, sorry.
AUDIENCE: I'm going
as Amelia Earhart.
ROBIN LOWEY: Nice.
AUDIENCE: Sweet.
ROBIN LOWEY: Well, we
don't know about her.
We have to wonder.
AUDIENCE: There is--
there is some letters.
ROBIN LOWEY: Is there?
Nice.
AUDIENCE: There was-- there
was a man that was asking her
to marry him for a really
long time, and she, finally--
she kept saying
no, no, no, no, no,
and there's all these letters
back and forth about it,
and she finally said, at
some point, she's like,
listen, we all know that
I'm not interested in this.
But I can't take the pressure
of expectation anymore.
So if we are going
to do this, you
have to understand
that I'm going
to go do my own separate thing.
And then she was in a
horrible plane accident
and didn't have to
ever marry anybody.
ROBIN LOWEY: Wow!
I wonder if that was rigged.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: Whoa!
CECILIA: All right,
ROBIN LOWEY: Or thoughts?
CECILIA: Let's think
Robin for coming today.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]